[Music]
[Applause]
bruce arians is partnering with rivals
media mobile game
where fans can predict outcomes for the
buccaneers games when prizes donate to
the arians family foundation which
supports
at-risk youth plans fans can play for
free
at aryans.rivalsmedia.com as we welcome
in the buccaneers head coach
coach thanks for joining us uh did you
watch the national title game
i sure did and uh what a game what a
team
what do you take away from how do you
watch that game as a coach or as a fan
oh definitely as a coach you are
watching the ebb and flow of the game
and uh the excitement of it you know
early in the ball game i said we got to
have a heck of a game i don't know if
either one of them is going to stop the
other one and then alabama's defense
really rose up and uh
well that the big three of alabama might
be the best big three to come out of
college in a long time
but when you see devonta smith what do
you see in how that translates to the
nfl
no it did translate he's got instant
speed
he's got one of those bodies that he can
twist and turn and make those shoulder
back shoulder catches look routine and
they're not routine
um he's strong he's slender but he's
strong and
he will make a great transition i also
am not sure about this and you being a
quarterbacks guy when you see
someone like mac jones he's surrounded
by all this talent
but if you're assessing his talent how
hard it is is it to
remove the talent around him to just
assess his talents
well i think the first thing you look
for in a quarterback is
a brain he's obviously a really really
bright young man
and then accuracy and he has he has
great accuracy with the ball
uh he is not one of the more mobile guys
that some people really love
but if you're gonna play from the pocket
and move him around like they do
um very much similar to what we do
he's a very talented young man who does
devonta smith
remind you of
he's kind of a mixture of calvin ridley
and julio jones he's got the height
speed you know not quite the bulk of
julio but
the the slipperiness of calvin i mean
that they were
alabama's turned out some great
receivers he might be one of the best
next to julio
and they got that he's got that
different gear like very
very few people coach have that gear
where you go whoa
that's that's that's game changing speed
yeah and it's frightening because he
doesn't look like he has it
he's just gliding and uh when he takes
those screens and turns the corners
i mean those are great players at ohio
state also a lot of speed and
just makes them look slow uh it's just
absolutely amazing to me
i see you got uh bear bryant a picture
over your shoulder is that a is that a
painting or a photo
it was a cover of time magazine uh it's
been with me since 1983
and it's always down that side but uh
one of my players
fathers gave it to me in temple
university my first year
and uh it's always been with me it uh
he always sits over my right shoulder
did you ever meet coach
hi coach foreign uh his last two years i
was assistant at alabama
oh okay so you take even great greater
pride in alabama winning last night
yeah if i have to root for another team
than virginia tech it's probably alabama
it's still temple if you were going to
explain bear bryant
to somebody who had never seen him off
your experience
how would you explain bear bryant
uh and in football acumen the best
personal
personnel manager i've ever seen because
people don't realize
we played 66 players in every game he
substituted every player
offense defense special teams you get
your tail fired if you send a player
across that sideline
and i saw that almost happen but uh just
just a master of people uh he can
recognize a viewer too high
too low and just one word from him he
loved ripping my ass and he loved
picking up everybody else
talking to bruce arians the buccaneers
defeated washington on saturday night
they got the saints coming up
on sunday night on fox let me go back to
that game
with washington how much tape did you
have on taylor heineken
very very little very very little you
knew he was he was
an athletic guy uh until you see those
young guys like that
in the moment you don't know if they
have it or not that kid's got it
i mean he was calm he was accurate he
obviously was very very slippery
and uh so i would think he just made a
name for himself that he'll be in the
league for a while
but do you go back to his old dominion
tape when he was in college
no we just looked at what we had a
little bit we had of the of the nfl
and you said after the game that and i'm
paraphrasing washington's front
didn't really make you nervous or
concern you at all uh
is that an accurate quote yeah it's
pretty accurate i mean everybody had to
have you got to have a story line going
into every game and when chase said he
wanted tom that became the story line
uh they're they're a heck of a young
front don't get me wrong but i knew our
guys would take the challenge
and and have been playing so well i
didn't think it'd be too big of a
problem
what's been the biggest surprise about
tom brady for you
i i think the way he handles younger
players
he's another coach i mean he really is i
mean the athletic stuff
is shocking for guy 43 but the way he
handles young guys and old guys he's
coaching non-stop
and it's a it always pisses me off
because i'll say something to a player
and they'll look at me he says it [ __ ]
okay tom i'll do it
[Laughter]
who yells at the younger players more
tom are you i think i got him beat on
that one but uh
it uh game day might be him could you
see him as a coach
when it's all said and done no i i think
he is probably
like peyton uh if they were you wouldn't
want to work for them
because they're perfectionists and they
wouldn't accept anything but perfection
and every now and then you gotta give a
little and it's interesting that you say
that because
i would talk to tony dungy about peyton
say how would he be as an analyst
he said well he would be great but he
would drive you crazy
because he would he would do so much
research he would he would drive your
researchers
crazy because of his preparation is is
brady and and peyton similar like that
very very similar i used to call peyton
the piranha because
if i had a 20-minute meeting i'd have to
have an hour and a half worth of
just to keep him occupied and the poor
other quarterbacks they couldn't take
notes fast enough
but uh and tom's exact same way their
attention to detail is
unbelievable because you go into these
meetings and you're the coach and you
want to be able to tell the player
something
peyton's telling you probably more than
you're supposed to be telling him
it's like did you see this corner did
you see this left corner yeah you mean
26 he said yeah watch his hips
watch his hips i'm like that's good
oh does brady make you laugh oh all the
time
between he and gronk now it's it's it's
hilarious sometimes but uh
on the field two of the most serious
dudes i've ever coached
but gronk like i never know if he's
putting on a show as an
act or he's really like that coach oh
that's gronk
that's just the way he walks on the
field and uh
there's a swagger there but it's a it's
a lot of fun
it's a lot of fee and joy is doing what
he's doing that's for sure can there be
any surprises in this
game the third game with the saints so
you you know the personnel
everybody knows everybody can there be
should there be surprises in this game
i don't think so i mean there'll be a
trick player too you know new orleans
has got a great bag of tricks and uh
with
taysom hill and everybody else um and
they got great athletes but
marshawn lattimore knows michael evans
and on and on and on you know it's a
turnover battles but we've lost this
game on turnovers and uh
that's something we have to we have to
address but if i said you can take out
michael thomas or you can take out alvin
kamara you get that option
who are you taking out of the game well
for us it would probably be michael
thomas
we knock on wood we've done a decent job
of of keeping alvin under control
our run game defense has been
outstanding but
michael thomas has hurt us yeah and him
just coming back and uh
looking pretty good in this this last
game camaro i'm never quite sure
like um is he a hybrid is he a true
running back to you or
who does he remind you of oh edgar and j
i mean
not marshall falk a little bit edwin
james marshall falk i mean
a guy with tremendous speed great runner
especially outside zone runner
and then he's a wide receiver he has so
many
ways he can beat you and no home field
advantage
how much does that factor in if it does
at all
it's huge i'm glad there's gonna be
three thousand because when we were
there for the opener it was
dead i mean dead dead and it's like
it was eerie at least we'll have some
noise
also you want that ambiance oh i want to
hear people booing or cheering i want to
hear all that yeah i mean it adds to the
game i mean that that dead silence or
that that airplane noise
it's something good when you can hear
like the air conditioner buzzing or
whatever
the lights are buzzing overhead that
does that has to be a surreal feeling
i mean going to monday night football in
new york and thursday night in chicago
and not hearing a sound
uh it's just it's it's mind-boggling to
me it's i've been in this game too long
and
the crowd the fans that they're the game
but do you have to be more quiet
on the sidelines when you're yelling
instructions or anything does brady have
to be quiet when he's in the huddle
uh not any more than normal you know
defenses are getting their signals
you're getting
your signals but uh cussing out referees
is probably the hardest thing
are you allowed to do they give you
leeway to to curse them out
yes and no i mean if you're smart you
just turn your back
[Laughter]
they may think you're yelling at
somebody else when you're yelling at
them
no they can't flag you if you're not
face to face
well you got your mask on too so they i
got a mask and a shield so i don't think
it counts
oh hey it's great to talk to you again
and uh have fun against new orleans
thanks for joining us
appreciate it brother and i invite you
to be on our celebrity guest panel for
the
rivals it's fun that's uh
uh aryans.rivalsmedia.com
and i'll give the plug i'll say goodbye
to you coach i know you got more
important things to do thanks for
joining us
but uh bruce is partnering with rivals
media it's a mobile game where fans
predict the outcomes
of the bucks games win prizes and uh
you're able to donate to the aryans
family foundation which
supports at-risk youth fans can play for
free it's
aryans.rivalsmedia.com